okay first of all I think I'm more
excited than you are you know how much I
think you deserve this thank you so much
like genuinely surprised none of us are
surprised yeah I just you know I've been
to the prom a few times yeah I mean I
don't know what else to say I love that
I get to do what I get to do so this is
like whipped cream on ice cream but were
you when you got up there I mean you he
seemed shocked do you know it was like
we all know like what an incredible
entertainer you are right it really yeah
I think because it's I mean it's always
it's been years and years but you showed
up many times and so just amazing to be
here and part of this whole community in
the love in that room is astounding you
could tell everybody was so did you feel
the love in the room yeah I did well I
did the audience is everything and I you
know we're in this all together
everything the highs the lows we're in
all of it together can I tell you the
backstage back here when you won like it
broken - like applause and cheers and
you know like I think we all felt like
she's getting tears in her eyes
[Music]
backstage like we were all like breaking
in to cheers and yells and you got a lot
of fans thank you and immense gratitude
to every one of you thank you thank you
are you guys gonna celebrate I have no
idea our kids are at the hotel right now
so we're gonna run there really fast and
yeah celebrate with them yeah and even
go out in Vegas at all you - probably
not we do we love Vegas we get here a
lot gonna see shows yeah it's a great
figure out like gamble a little bit you
know she is good I do just a little bit
half hour and then I'm done
win or lose usually breakeven
not losing right thing to say what
you're so deserving I'm so happy I mean
you know I'm gonna say that I called it
on the red carpet you know wow thank you
I feel like tonight's the night you
deserve it for so many time you know
just interjected myself into this whole
thing
[Music]